hi it's michelle from lab muffin beauty
science here chemistry phd skin care nerd
and someone who really likes foaming cleansers
there are a lot of myths about foaming cleansers
and the ingredients in foaming cleansers and how
to use foaming cleansers so today i'm
going to be busting some of these myths
i asked you all to send me cleanser myths
in my instagram stories and i got so many
replies thank you so much it was actually
really helpful because there were so many
myths that i already had in mind but
also so many that i just forgot about
a word of warning before we begin the answer
to a lot of these is going to be it depends it
won't be a simple yes or no i know it isn't as
satisfying and a lot of us just want certainty
but unfortunately a lot of stuff in skincare
is quite complex a lot of the time the research
hasn't really come to a firm conclusion yet and a
lot of myths do have a little bit of truth to them
i also talk more about cleansing and all the other
important steps in a skincare routine in my ebook
the lab muffin guide to basic skin care
so check that out if you want more info
the first myth is are foaming cleansers always bad
for your skin are foaming cleansers harsher than
other cleansers this used to be true back in the
day with older cleansers the only ingredient that
was commonly used to make lots of foam was sodium
lauryl sulfate a bit of background on cleansing
ingredients cleansing ingredients are called
surfactants they have this sort of structure
they have a head that likes water and a tail that
likes oil the two together in the one package
means that surfactants can help oil lift off skin
and surfaces and disperse into water so you can
actually rinse it off sodium lauryl sulfate is
the surfactant and it happens to be quite skinny
for a surfactant that means it can penetrate into
skin more easily and stay there and that's what
leads to irritation and that tight feeling you
sometimes get after you wash off a cleanser but
with newer cleansers firstly there are lots more
ways to produce lots of foam and secondly there
are ways to formulate with sodium lauryl sulfate
that stops it from being quite as irritating
first let's talk about foam products that
foam a lot don't necessarily clean better
and they don't necessarily irritate more the
three can correlate but they don't always
it's like owning cats versus happiness versus
spending a lot of money the three are sort of
linked but not really so foam cleansing and
irritation they all have a lot to do with
surfactants but foam making is to do with how well
surfactants stabilize a liquid film that traps air
cleansing ability is to do with how well
surfactants pull oil and dirt off skin
now you might have thought that cleansing too
well cleansing too much stuff off your skin
is also what causes irritation and scientists
thought this for a really long time but it turns
out that's not the main reason for irritation
the main part of irritation is actually how well
a surfactant burrows into skin and stays there
and disrupts your skin barrier with foam there
are now lots of surfactants that can foam really
well without being as irritating as sls glucosides
betaines sultaines ether sulfates sarcosinates
taurates isethionates are all very good at foaming
there are also lots of non-surfactant ingredients
that are really good at stabilizing foam
and these don't necessarily add to irritation
so these are things like glycerin and thickeners
foaming pump tops are also getting more popular so
even if a cleanser doesn't foam well when you just
rub it on your hands the packaging can increase
the foam there are also lots of ingredients that
can be added to cleansers to make them less
irritating and this is a lot more common now
for example it turns out that adding emollients
which are moisturizing ingredients to a foaming
cleanser can make it less irritating than
a non-foaming cleanser without these added
ingredients in this study over five days the
non-foaming cleanser actually dried out skin
while the foaming cleanser with these added
emollients actually increase skin hydration
over the five days so yeah modern foaming
cleansers can be very very gentle that actually
ticks off another myth i got asked which is can
cleansers actually hydrate and moisturize skin
and this study seems to say yes some can and this
makes sense because cleansers can actually deliver
active ingredients which i'm going to talk about a
little bit later but first i wanted to talk about
sulfates are sodium lauryl sulfate and sodium
laureth sulfate as bad as everyone makes them out
to be again historically sodium lauryl sulfate was
quite harsh but in modern cleansers there are lots
of ways to make sodium lauryl sulfate less harsh
the most common way is to combine sodium lauryl
sulfate with other surfactants in the one cleanser
and this is really common practice i don't
remember the last time i saw sodium lauryl sulfate
in a cleanser by itself the way this works is
once you mix a cleanser with water you get lots of
individual surfactant molecules floating around by
themselves as well as big clusters called micelles
now remember the main thing that makes cleansers
irritating is when the individual surfactant
molecules can burrow into skin and sodium lauryl
sulfate is very skinny it's very narrow which
means it's really good at doing this but it can't
do this when it's in a big cluster the micelle
is too big so it's actually those individual
molecules that didn't get into the micelles
floating around by themselves that can burrow
into skin and cause that irritation so one really
good approach to making sodium lauryl sulfate less
irritating is to try to get more of them into
these micelles the scientific term for this is
to lower the critical micelle concentration
it turns out if you use a bunch of different
surfactant molecules to make micelles these mixed
micelles they actually incorporate more of the sls
into them and that means less individual molecules
that can get into skin and less irritation using
a mixture of surfactants to do the job also means
that you can reduce the concentration of the more
irritating surfactants there are other special
technologies as well like using polymers that
stick onto surfactants again forming a much larger
cluster and not letting them get into your skin
another common practice is to add ingredients that
reduce irritation into the cleanser for example
polymers emollients hydrolyzed proteins glycerin
and antioxidants so just seeing sodium lauryl
sulfate on a cleanser ingredient list doesn't
mean that cleanser will be irritating and if
you're using a cleanser that you really like but
it happens to have sodium lauryl sulfate in it
that's not a reason to stop using it but if you're
looking for a cleanser and your skin is quite
sensitive or prone to dryness and irritation and
there are a few different cleanser options you're
looking at maybe picking the one that doesn't
have sodium lauryl sulfate might be a better bet
so that is sodium lauryl sulfate what about
sodium laureth sulfate well i think sodium
laureth sulfate just got swept along with sodium
lauryl sulfate because they sound kind of the
same and the word sulfate is really easy to
say there's an older experiment that tested
the irritancy of a range of different surfactants
including surfactants that we still use a lot now
sodium laureth sulfate turned out to be the
mildest as well as beating sodium lauryl sulfate
it also beat two other sulfates tea lauryl
sulfate and ammonium lauryl sulfate and it
beat these ones and you can sort of see why these
didn't really take off in the fearmongering states
disodium cocoampho sodium lauro sodium
lauro sodium lauro i am a trained chemist
with a phd disodium cocoamphodiacetate sodium
lauroamphoacetate sodium cocoyl methyl taurate
do you have to cleanse your skin for a certain
amount of time 30 seconds one minute two minutes
the answer is no not really your skin doesn't
have to marinate in cleanser to work but
using a cleanser for a little bit longer might
give you better results let me explain so i
mentioned that cleansers have surfactants and they
arrange themselves into clusters called micelles
when you use the cleanser what has to happen is
the oil and dirt has to make it into the middle of
the micelles so this situation on the left has to
rearrange itself into the situation on the right
the oil has to break up into droplets and get
suspended into the water by the surfactants
once you have these emulsion droplets they
can be rinsed away it's sort of like the oil
is dissolving into the water so to make them
rearrange you have to shuffle stuff around
the molecules quite like being in the second
version so if you jostle them around enough
they'll naturally rearrange like that so that's
what you're doing when you're rubbing a cleanser
on your face you're jostling everything around
and trying to get this oil to break up into these
emulsion droplets you can also use a cleansing
brush or a sponge or whatever to make them move
molecules also wiggle around a lot randomly so
if you just leave it they'll eventually bump
around enough that they'll rearrange into that
second version but if you're adding movement
using your fingers or a cleansing brush or
whatever then you don't have to wait as long
it's like trying to clean an oily plate you could
leave it in soapy water for an hour or you could
scrub it and you'll be done in 10 seconds so time
isn't really the limiting factor it's moving the
molecules around enough that they rearrange into
the second version so you can wash them away
obviously you can't physically rub the cleanser
all over your face in half a second none of us
are the flash i think flash if you're watching hi
but if you could it would be enough so that's why
these recommendations for 30 seconds one minute
two minutes can be helpful it's the same logic
as brush your teeth for two minutes or clean
your house for 15 minutes every day if you make
yourself spend more time doing something then that
indirectly makes you do it more thoroughly even if
there's no magic behind the exact length of time
itself now the problem with leaving a cleanser
on for too long so for example if you leave it
on like a mini mask even though the directions
don't say that is that it can be irritating
cleansers are designed to be washed off your skin
if you look at the recommendations for ingredient
usage by formulators so how much of an ingredient
you should be putting into different products
for potentially irritating ingredients the
amount for a leave on product is going to be
lower than the amount for a wash off product
and that is because of the different contact
time the longer you leave something on your skin
the more time there is for the ingredients in
that product to get into your skin and for some
ingredients you don't want that so for example
the surfactants there are lots of surfactants used
in rinse off cleansers that shouldn't be left
on skin so the longer you leave that cleanser
on your skin the more time those surfactants have
to burrow into your skin and stay there and cause
irritation other ingredients with different
recommendations for leave on and wash off are
things like fragrances preservatives essential
oils so the moral of the story is don't just
let a cleanser sit on your skin for those 30
seconds or one minute or two minutes make sure
you're moving it around on your skin otherwise
there's no extra benefit to leaving it on
now there is an exception with cleansers that
contain actives where the instructions actually
say to leave them on your skin for a certain
amount of time then hopefully they did their
due diligence they tested it on lots of people
and they found that most people didn't have
issues with that extra irritation in
which case just follow the instructions
now whether or not active ingredients can actually
work in a cleanser obviously a cleanser doesn't
stay in contact with your skin for as long as a
leave-on product so there's less opportunity for
the ingredients to penetrate your skin and get to
where they need to be to work so the challenge is
making that ingredient stick to the skin better
than it stays in the cleanser and so when you
rinse it off there's still stuff stuck to your
skin with face cleansers there are a few active
ingredients that can be successfully delivered
so for example salicylic acid benzoyl peroxide
if we look at other cleansing products as
well with body washes they can deliver oily
substances really well like stearic acid
lanolin alcohol plant oils and even dha
which is the active ingredient in self-tan
if we look at shampoos we have anti-dandruff
shampoos that deliver those active ingredients
purple shampoos can deliver purple hair dye and
two-in-one shampoos can deliver conditioning
ingredients so it's definitely possible
that cleansers can leave behind enough active
ingredients to make a difference to your skin
and they don't all wash down the drain and i'm
sure there's tons of other actives that can be
successfully delivered that just haven't been
studied yet the problem is a lot of the time
you need to have a special delivery system to
convince the ingredient to stick to your skin
in general if it's something more oil soluble
then it tends to stick to skin better the problem
for us as consumers is that it's really hard to
tell if a product has the right delivery system
unless the brand actually tells you and leaving
it on your skin for too long can cause all of
those problems that we talked about before
so i would still recommend leaving cleansers
on your skin for as long as the product says to
leave it don't leave it on for like five minutes
and expect to have good results at that point you
are probably doing more harm than good in general
i would probably recommend using a leave-on
product rather than a cleanser if you really
want an active ingredient it's just a bit more
reliable there's a lot more evidence for leave
on products and you don't have to worry about
how long to leave it on your skin for but there
are definitely some situations where a cleanser
with active ingredients might be a better option
if your skin is quite sensitive to a particular
ingredient then using it in a cleanser might be
a better choice you can also apply the leave-on
product and just wash it off after 10 minutes
or 30 minutes if you're worried about irritation
this has been shown to work quite well for some
ingredients like retinoids and benzoyl
peroxide i talked more about this short
contact therapy in my video about starting on
retinoids i think it's also a really good idea
for benzoyl peroxide apart from the irritation
there's also the fact that benzoyl peroxide is
a massive pain in the (what what in the) benzoyl
peroxide also bleaches things like pillowcases
and clothes and towels benzoyl peroxide
is also like the ingredient that causes
issues with layering it inactivates a lot of
other active ingredients so if you just wash
it off before you apply the rest of your
routine you don't have to worry about it
so those are the most popular cleansing
myths i got asked about i'm sorry if i
didn't get to your myth i will hopefully cover
it next time like subscribe nerdification bell
you can also check out my blog and follow me on
instagram i'll see you next time for more nerdery